rabat est un curé qui sont très copains
et ils se parlent et le rabbin et
regarde le curé il lui dit mais comment
comment tu fais pour être gros comme ça
il y vraiment eu dit-il routier ils
disent et c'est ta communauté qui te
donne jean ont ils dit pas du tout il
dit mais moi j'ai une technique au
restaurant me dis c'est quoi la
technique il dit je vais manger au
restaurant je mange comme 4 et quand on
m'amène l'addition jeudi mais monsieur
j'ai déjà payé grassement à la serveurs
dit bah non monsieur je vous emmène
l'addition débat allait quand même pas
mettre en doute la parole d'un homme de
foi il à être car du temps le type prend
l'addition et s'en va et il est excusé
d'où mon père on s'est trompé e-dialog
saïdis ac c'est malin ça le lendemain le
rabat il va dans un restaurant casher il
mange comme 8 arrive l'addition il dit
ça va j'ai déjà payé weekly non monsieur
vous n'avez pas payé on vient nous
amener addition ai dit comment moi le
rabbi vous allez mettre en doute ma
parole et dit non il dit rabih excusez
nous on pensait qu'on a et rabat il sera
soit il attend une demi heure trois
quarts d'heure une heure le garçon est
bien il fait ya un problème dit oui un
problème j'attends la monnaie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jeune homme va voir son père lui dit
papa je voudrais sortir ce soir et les
non tu as 16 ans bientôt 17 tu sens pas
tout seul le soir ni papa je t'en
supplie c'est samedi
il ya une fête hyper importante laisse
moi sortir dit non et dit s'il te plaît
laisse moi sorti il dit je vais te
laisser sortir mais à une heure du matin
tu es là et s'il ya une heure du matin
t'es pas là tu vas voir à faire
sérieusement à moi il dit papa je te
jure à une heure je suis là verdi ok il
est sortir le gosse à une heure du matin
le père attend est le gars sait toujours
pas là deux heures legault s'est
toujours pas là trois heures personnes
le père devient fou il tourne en ai dit
tu dis voir sa gueule quand il va
rentrer 4h 5h 6h à 7h le montrent il y
aura une explication très sévère tous
les deux il dit papa j'ai une bonne
raison et y avait je serai curieux de
l'entente la baisse ce soir j'ai fait
l'amour pour la première fois à bon ben
ok tu veux qu'on en parle tu veux ta
soirée dit je veux bien qu'on en parle
mais je veux pas m'asseoir
une histoire belge mais sous son
contrôle avec l'accent que je maîtrise à
un couple de belges et sa femme lui dit
à son mari il faudrait que tu change
vraiment le papier pas dis moi oui oui
il comment faire un petit coup tu
devrais aller demander à roger en
dessous il a fait la semaine dernière
il descend il fait roger excuse moi de
te déranger
ma femme voudrait qu'on refasse le
papier il paraît qu la fed oui j'en ai
fait et dit combien il faut de rouleaux
pas du 30 de l'etranger ou l'audio et 32
rouleau il fâché le tapissier ils
achètent 32 rouleau il y passe quatre
jours il appelle sa femme ellie là
vraiment je ne comprends pas a dit mme à
quoi va exiger tout tapissé 1 to de
moindres recoins
il me reste quatre rouleaux à dire un
bon c'est étrange pourtant j'ai demandé
à au ghk exactement ce qui m'a dit et on
a la même surface il me laisse 4 où
l'eau m'a dit va lui demander qu ils
descendent vers geste soit heureux
déranger reçus mais j'ai fais comme tu
m'as dit j'ai acheté 32 rouleau il me
reste quatre est objectivement aussi
mauvaise 4
un mec sort de chez lui hier matin pour
aller travailler et il ya un type qui
est en bas de chez lui et qui en le
voyant pas sans lui fait cocu coquema
pardon me suis fait cocu cocu une femme
monsieur soit pas bien non mais qui
descend le mec le suit larry fait cocu
cocu le mec descente prend le métro le
mec monde dans la même rame que lui et
de loin lui fait cocu cocu mec devient
dingue
il ya jusqu'à son bureau comme ça ibos
le soir hiro descend à 18h le même mec
là d'un il fait ça cocu mais répond pas
il fait cocu cocu cocu il y en a de plus
en plus voir un mec dans le métro par le
mexique en face au cul mais grande chez
lui dit ah ce fameux ya un truc que je
trouve quand même assez étrange
il ya un mec qui m'a suivi toute la
journée qui m'a traité de con qu elle
fait et bailly je trouve ça bizarre tu
as rien à venir feu non monsieur était
pas bien non ça il ya un dégénéré qui
traite de cocu dans la rue ça va être de
ma fautif énorme enfin effet non mais ça
va c'est vrai mais enfin quand même je
vous fais un bon mec va se coucher
lendemain matin il se réveille il a
bossé il ya le même mec qui fait cocu et
rapporteur en plus c'est une histoire de
cet instinct coupe de pieds noirs
ouais oui le mec se lève le matin il va
dans la salle de bain ils constatent le
robinet fuit il va sa femme elle dort
encore il fait ça et 18 mois et puis
pourquoi ce fut encore elle dit j'ai
appelé le dif est le idou je suis
plombier il dit je travaille comme une
bête
il y appelle le plombier il vient il
répare et dit [ __ ] c'est pas compliqué
il dit si comme le gazon là il est
patent du dîner elle dit elle dit mais
fait lui ai dit d'où je suis jardinier
et dit je travaille appelle le jardinet
mme lemay 30 le soir le gazon tondu
nickel il va dans la salle de bal
robinet fuit fais à ma femme
ils ont la journée qui a fait venir et
le plombier jardiner devinant maurice à
côté lui les gentils je lui ai dit à mon
gazon il est trop il ya ma robinetterie
elle marche pas il a dit d'accord je te
fais tout mais tu me fais une gâterie ou
alors tu me fais un bon gâteau il y à
l'heure tu dois faire mon gâteau elle
fait 12e suis pâtissier
[Applaudissements]